lashana it's good to see you can i tell
you oh hi
i was so excited years ago when they
announced that you were going to be part
of this film and the first black female
1007 and now it's finally out has it
kind of hit you now what this moment
actually means no
no no nothing's hit right nothing's hit
me at all i was just saying the other
day actually that it feels like my my
feelings are just like they exploded at
one point unbeknownst to me they're all
on the floor now at some point i just
got to slowly pick them up and put them
together and see what the picture is
because from where i'm standing it just
seems like a
ball of excitement which it is but i'm
sure one day the penny will drop
yeah it's surreal and then to see you on
the red carpet in london we're in
vivian's westwood and you're meeting
duchess kate what did she say to you
what was that moment like for you
oh if i can remember it i think you just
there's so much
so much going through your head that
you're just like i mean firstly her
dress was amazing and we were talking
about our dresses and then she was just
talking about this moment in history and
i i i remember the feeling of it which
was beautiful
i i actually have just realized that i
don't remember everything that was said
because it whips you by
so quickly but she was lovely and it was
it was such a lovely moment as well at
the end
and you're so badass at this film
especially that scene where you take
your glasses off and you're driving the
aston martin it was just a beautiful
moment what has it meant for you to be
part of the last hurrah with daniel
craig as as bond
oh it's it's been amazing it really has
he's he's been uh
amazing to watch on set just seeing how
he holds himself has he as he carries
everyone and is across every single
department really paying attention to
everything because everything matters to
him he's so dedicated
and he never felt like it was his last
bond movie it felt like he
was just going through it trying to
enjoy every single moment because
you know it first starts with a couple
years and next thing you know it's we've
got two months and we've got two weeks
and then two days and then we're out you
know so it was wonderful to watch him
and to learn from him
how did your family friends react have
they seen it
they have yeah they have it was um there
was some tears there was some screaming
there was just some oh
oh all of that oh
no words kind of moments it was an
amalgamation of things that make me just
really proud to come from the people
that i come from and even their their
silence i know exactly what what they're
feeling inside and i guess with them
it's no words too so kind of similar to
me
have you said the famous line have you
said
jane bond james bond have you said it
out loud no
no i haven't actually
i'm like daniel
go ahead say your names it's fine
but you haven't what you're gonna have
to say i mean you own the name double
seven so
you know potentially in the future we
could have you saying that
i mean no me i don't even
we didn't finalize a nomi's surname i
mean i do there are two that we there's
one that i think it is
a little longer
and then we'll discuss it in c that's if
she returns we'll have to see what the
future holds i hope she does i hope she
does and finally your martini do you
like a shaken or str
oh my word
i am the the worst when it comes to
cocktails i would be like shake and
stirred shake and stirred for about half
an hour with the barman and then decide
to just go with
sparkling water or something
so
i don't know i'll leave i'll leave that
to the professionals like like james
bond i love it congratulations to you
i'm so proud of you and this movie's
epic so uh congratulations to the whole
team so thank you so much for chatting
with me really appreciate it
thank you thank you so much